dogmatism
as a way of thinking whether in ordinary
knowing
or in the study of philosophy is nothing
else but the opinion that the true
consists in a proposition which is a
fixed result or which is immediately
known
to such questions as when was caesar
born or
how many feet were there in a stadium
etc
a clear-cut answer ought to be given
just as it is definitely true that the
square
on the hypotenuse is equal to the sum of
the squares on the other two sides of a
right angle triangle
but the nature of a so-called truth of
that kind is different from the nature
of philosophical truths
when we hear or see or use this term
dogmatism today
what we often have come to mind is this
notion of the dogmatic person as being
somebody who's very stubborn very set in
their ways being
unwilling to question their way of
viewing things
to hear other other people's you know
points of view
and that is a part of it but
you know the term has an older and wider
significance and you're going to
see this is a little bit circular at the
start dogmatism
is the standpoint that begins from a
dogma
when we hear this term dogma i think
most of us will tend to associate that
with another you know qualifier
religious dogma
as being that which you have to believe
in if you're going to be ex so
if you're going to be a buddhist look
you have to believe in reincarnation you
have to believe that the point of things
is to you know attain release into
nirvana if you're going to be a
christian then you have to believe that
jesus christ was was god and man
if you're going to be you know we could
go on through all these sorts of things
now why would you have to believe it
well this goes back to the earlier sense
of dogma that was taken on
by religious communities dogma first had
its use in greek philosophy and what a
dogma is
is a notion or an idea
or some sort of you know basic starting
point
that certain schools of philosophy
thought
if you don't begin from this
then you're not going to get anywhere
else
so you you have to actually accept
x y and z or else you're not going to be
able to make any progress
so dogmatism comes to mean having some
sort of unquestioned
assumptions and then it gets the sense
of having you know unquestioned
assumptions perhaps of religious nature
perhaps of a scientific nature there
there are things called the central
dogma
of this or the central dogma of that and
they mean very much the same thing
it's an unquestioned assumption and if
somebody says well i don't want to
believe in that then you just say to
them well then fine you're not going to
make any progress in this field
you're not going to be able to
understand things because this is a
basic component a basic building block
a basic keystone sometimes that you need
to hold things together
so uh hegel is is worried about
dogmatism as a way of thinking and he
says this can happen in ordinary
knowing our knowledge of things in the
world we can be dogmatic that way
or in philosophy and he says it's
nothing else but the opinion
that the true consists in a proposition
which is he says a fixed result or is
immediately known
dogmatism is a term that kant had used
and he was opposing it to both
skepticism and his own transcendental
philosophy
dogmatic philosophy was felt to be not
truly philosophical
hegel is following up on that and he's
saying
if you think that the truth is you know
encapsulated
in propositions that
are a fixed result something that you
can rely on
once you've got it in your hand you can
say aha now i've got it i'm going to put
it into a handbook
and i'll just read this and i'll have
the truth with me all the time
or that it's something immediately known
something that you don't have to put any
thought into something that you don't
have to actually
work on and work towards then
you're going to have a dogmatic
perspective which leads you away from
doing genuine philosophy you might call
what you're doing philosophy
but it's not really philosophical and
this would actually apply to
to much of what goes under the rubric of
philosophy today
so hegel gives you examples to such
questions as when was caesar born or how
many feet were there in a stadium that's
a roman
measure a clear-cut answer ought to be
given
just as it is definitely true that the
square on the hypotenuse is equal to the
sum of the squares on the other two
sides of a right-handed triangle
no problem with that you know historical
knowledge
mathematical knowledge that's fine
that's actually knowledge that can in
fact be encapsulated
in a proposition that can be a fixed
result we don't have to question
who caesar was every time that we bring
up caesar or abraham lincoln
you know we might we might want to have
new um
you know reassessments or
interpretations but you know we're gonna
unless we have new evidence we're gonna
stick with the fixed result that's okay
there are some things that can be
immediately known is coffee bitter
taste it and find out you don't need to
do philosophy in order to talk about
coffee
but the nature of a so-called truth of
that kind
he says is different from the nature of
philosophical truths
when we're doing philosophy we can't
just stick with the positive this is why
positivism
is actually not only you know a
misguided way of understanding
philosophy it's a
terrible thing to engage in because it
leads you astray it leads you away from
the possibility of actually learning how
to do genuine philosophy
by having the aim of only what can be
measured
you know publicly verified et cetera et
cetera et cetera
you restrict yourself to what's
inherently unphilosophical
hegel would say so long story short we
want to avoid dogmatism
in philosophy nothing wrong with with
you know true propositions that are
fixed results are immediately known
it's just that they're not going to
provide us with the sort of foundation
or basis
that we need in order to genuinely carry
out the process
and projects of philosophy
as regards historical truths to mention
these briefly
it will be readily granted that so far
as their purely historical aspect is
considered
they are concerned with a particular
existence with the contingent
and arbitrary aspects of a given content
which have no necessity
but even such plain truths as those just
illustrated are not without the movement
of self-consciousness
to cognize one of them a good deal of
comparison is called for
books must be consulted in some way or
other inquiry has to be made
even in even an immediate intuition is
held to have genuine value
only when it is cognized as a fact along
with its reasons
although it is probably only the bare
result that we are supposed to be
concerned about
in section 41 hegel is going to speak
very briefly
about what he is calling historical
bashir
truths and by this we should we should
imagine
something more than just what we tend to
bring to mind when we think of the
discipline of history
what he means by historical truths are
anything that falls within the realm
of the particular the contingent the
arbitrary that which actually
has happened or people report to have
happened so you could think of a police
report for example
as falling under what he's calling
historical truths or
an economics report as as falling under
that as well and
what is his concern in in bringing this
up
historical truth although philosophy is
going to be
grounded within the historical process
and very interested in the great meaning
underlying the historical process
philosophical truths are not going to be
historical truths of the sort that he's
outlining here
he says it'll be readily granted that so
far as their purely historical
aspect is concerned what makes them
primarily historical
they have these three qualities they are
particular
that is they they bear upon particulars
they don't aim to
tell us about or apply to things
universally
that's when we actually take historical
truths and then we generalize from them
when we do that we're leaving the
boundaries of history
proper so for example uh you know
it's always popular to compare america
or really any other nation that you like
that is some sort of
vast nation state uh encompassing a lot
of
disparate people with disparate beliefs
to the roman republic and empire and
talk about its decline
the actual process of decline of the
roman
empire is something that is within the
realm of historical truth extending that
to the current american regime
at any given time and comparing making
that comparison instead of comparing
america to
1930s france which would be an equally
apt comparison
that is where you're extending things
from
that body of data and information
that's been interpreted to some degree
which bears on a particular
time a particular set of people
particular events and trying to
generalize to another
admittedly particular thing if you were
going to try to derive
a general law of the rise and fall of
peoples from the roman empire what
you're doing is you're trying to go from
the particular to the universal
aristotle criticized history
rather backhandedly in his poetics in
saying that
poetry was more philosophical in history
because history historia which was
already
disciplined by that time focused on the
particular
focused on what had happened focused on
what was the case for individual
particular things and poetry look to the
universals
and you might say well how is that the
case i mean oedipus was one guy
well oedipus somehow stands for
something
whereas it's not quite so easy uh with
every historical circumstance to say
exactly what it stands for
um contingent contingent means that
things just
happen to be that way there could be
causes that somebody could have had some
ideas in mind
but it's the realm of 2k of chance of
con
you know of contingency and
arbitrary arbitrary goes beyond
the contingent and it's interesting that
he uses this term arbitrary
vil kurlik um
arbitras in in uh latin
is closely connected with voluntas
arbitras is sort of judgment or decision
and it's only beings that actually have
some sort of free will
that you know a
capacity to choose to differentiate
options and say i'm taking this one it's
only those that can make
arbitrary decisions
so the arbitrary goes beyond the
contingent
ville curling in german arbitrary
goes beyond that as well and involves
the notion of of the will
and history is in large part the product
of volitions
by people and you can take other
historical perspectives you can take
you know the the long duration of the
ana the the zanal
you know historians and do economic
analyses and say well people didn't
really have any
choice about the circumstances in which
they worked but this is one of the
the paradoxes of history actually that
we are dealing with beings that do make
make decisions so hegel says look as far
as the historical goes the purely
historical it's got these three things
even such plain truths as those just
just illustrated you know like um
when was caesar born he was born at this
place at this time did he have
asthma yes he did how did he overcome it
doing calisthenics with the soldiers
and spending time with them in the field
these are historical truths
he says even such plain truths as those
just illustrated are not without the
movement of self-consciousness and he
doesn't spell this out particularly well
in this section
and you can think of it as as existing
in two ways
what happened which is what the
historical truths are about
is the product of human
self-consciousness
in the past doing something choosing
something
thinking something assuming something
coming to a judgment
uh engaging in cooperation or
competition or agonistic
you know fighting with something else
overcoming itself succumbing to
something giving into temptation
self-consciousness decides
something and something then happens as
a result of that
so self-consciousness is involved there
but what we're doing as
historically looking backward thinking
beings
as the subject who is engaging
history as a kind of knowledge as a kind
of object
is we are what he says cognizing it we
are
thinking it and when we think it he says
there's
there's two ways in which this this goes
one
is through what we call inquiry
we ask what happened
and you know if you think about the
father of history you know
sometimes people might say well he
wasn't really the father of history it
was thucydides and said
let's just say herodotus because he used
the word history
and herodotus maybe he made up some
things but
but he also went around he asked people
questions and he also
looked in archives and he and he
compared things
he wanted to figure out how did these
persian wars take place
what was actually going on what were the
people
you know what were their decisions what
were their motivations
let me find that stuff out i'll actually
talk to people i'll carry out inquiry
and there we start getting a bit more
philosophical
because we're inquiring into
the reasons the why why
did things turn out the way that they
did that's going to take us
outside of the realm of the merely
historical as hegel sees it and into
something that's
if not philosophy at least headed in
that direction so he says
you know even an immediate intuition has
held that genuine value
only when it's cognized as a fact
along with its reasons facts
you know a lot of people want to
accumulate facts
particularly they love statistics this
is a good thing to think about because
we're moving into talking about
mathematical cognition
facts are contingent facts are arbitrary
they don't do you any damn good unless
you can actually put them into a network
and say
why they actually matter how you know
that they're actually true
whether we've actually you know
constituted them as
facts or whether they were sort of
reading our desires into them
unless you can come up with something
beyond the mere fact
the thing that people you know often
want to go back to as a kind of idol
you don't really know anything somebody
who only knows facts
lacks actual knowledge hegel would say
as for mathematical truths we should be
even less inclined to regard anyone as a
geometer who knew euclid's theorems
outwardly by rote without knowing their
proofs without
as we might say to point the contrast
knowing them
inwardly similarly if someone became
aware
through measuring a number of right
angled triangles that their sides do in
fact have the well-known
relation to one another we should
consider his mere
awareness of that fact unsatisfactory
yet even in mathematical cognition the
essentiality of the proof does not have
the significance and nature of being a
moment of the result itself
when the latter is reached the
demonstration is over and has
disappeared
it is of course as a result that the
theorem is something seen to be true
but this added circumstance has no
bearing on its content but only on its
relation to the knowing subject
the movement of mathematical proof does
not belong to the object but rather is
an activity
external to the matter at hand thus the
nature of the right angle triangle does
not divide itself into parts just the
way
set forth and the construction necessary
for the proof of the proposition that
expresses its ratio
the way in the means by which the result
is brought forth and
belong entirely to the cognitive process
in philosophical cognition too the way
in which the outer existence qua
existence of a thing comes about is
distinct from the way in which its
essence or inner nature comes to be
but to begin with philosophical
cognition includes both
existence and essence whereas
mathematical cognition sets forth only
the genesis of the existence that is
the being of the nature of the thing in
cognition as such
what is more philosophical cognition
also unites these two distinct processes
the inner coming to be or genesis of
substance is an
unbroken transition into outer existence
into being for another and conversely
the genesis of existence is how
existence
is by itself taken back into essence
the movement of is the twofold process
and the genesis of the whole
in such wise that each side
simultaneously posits the other
and each therefore has both perspectives
within itself
together they constitute the whole by
dissolving themselves
and by making themselves into its
moments
sections 42 through 46 are going to see
hegel engaging in some criticisms
and a broader critique by the way those
are not exactly the same thing
of mathematics and of what he calls
mathematical cognition the mathematical
way of of approaching knowledge
now why is he doing this that's one
question we ought to ask ourselves
and another question that we ought to
ask ourselves is
is he really being fair to mathematics
as we could understand it today
i tend to think that hegel is on base
with some things and a little bit off
base with
with certain other things
let's think first as we look at this
passage before we look at what he's he's
trying to say
let's think about what we often mean
when we say mathematics or
math in american english or maths
in in british english
what is distinctive to mathematics
we might think of mathematics as a type
of cognition and when we talk about this
term cognition
what do we mean a way of thinking a way
of acquiring knowledge where
knowledge wasn't previously
another thing that we might think of is
the
actual discipline embodied in textbooks
embodied in theorems and proofs
embodied in exercises embodied in
equations embodied in
all sorts of things mathematics is
something that you could go to college
to study as as i in fact
did sort of in a haphazard way i didn't
mean to be
become a math major i just started
taking calculus classes and liked it and
ended up doubling double majoring in
mathematics and philosophy when i was
undergraduate but doing that meant
studying the discipline of mathematics
and as it turns out mathematics
comprises a whole set of other
sub-disciplines some of which are are
you know easy to correlate with each
other some of which aren't so easy
um we might also think of it as a tool
or technique or as an entire
panoply of tools and techniques
particularly when we're thinking of you
know so-called applied mathematics as
opposed to pure mathematics
we might also think of it in terms of
the experts
the people who to us embody mathematics
i tend to think of this as a sort of
superstitious attitude to have
you know um it tends to be the sort of
thing that people who don't actually
know much about mathematics tend to
adopt towards those who
do seem to know quite a bit about
mathematics you know
one this is a total aside i think one of
the reasons
why it's so important for um
kindergarten through 12th grade and then
college students to actually study
mathematics
is not this you know notion that we have
that well it's going to be so important
to balance your checkbook
and to apply mathematics in your your
ordinary life
really one want to study mathematics
not just so that one can acquire the
rigorous habit of mathematical thinking
either
but so that one can understand when
people are trying to snow you with
it so that one doesn't have
and i an almost idolatrous peasant-like
attitude towards those who can actually
do things with numbers
you know aristotle said about rhetoric
that
the reason why people ought to study
rhetoric is so that they're not unarmed
when other people use it against them
because that's kind of shameful in his
words unmanly although you know i think
we could extend this to women as well
and i think we should say the same thing
about mathematics i think it's appalling
that that many students
in the united states uh adopt this this
popular attitude of i don't really need
to know mathematics and mathematics is
so tough and
and it's beyond me um it's not really
beyond anybody
that's my little soapbox thing which i
rarely indulge in but i think it's
useful to think
in in terms of mathematics as not just
being
one thing we have to be a little bit
careful with it
hegel is mainly talking about
mathematics as a type of cognition here
and he says that
when we're looking at mathematics you
know
when we look at mathematical truths
if somebody has only memorized equations
and they don't understand
why they ought to have them in mind or
what they would be used for or why the
equations would work out the way they
are
they don't really know mathematics they
don't really have
knowledge he says
knowing them outwardly by rote without
knowing their proofs
knowing them inwardly that's what it is
to know something through a proof
it's not enough even just to memorize
the proof you have to
be able to you have to have developed a
facility with with constructing proofs
you have to know how to get from point a
to point b and not be lost along the way
otherwise you're really just relying on
other people's maps
other people's landmarks you haven't
really made it your own
inwardly and remember the phenomenology
uh is all about us making
inward appropriating the entire
historical development of human
consciousness
so mathematics is a part of that and we
wouldn't consider somebody to actually
know
mathematics who can only reproduce
things and doesn't actually understand
them
but here's the problem hegel says with
mathematical knowledge
we have the proofs and so you know
imagine your way back to
say geometry class i remember taking
high school geometry
just hated it college geometry loved it
you know why
because in high school geometry all we
did was play around with you know
protractors and compasses
and do constructions and there was never
any sense of
why the hell we were doing this we had
to you know memorize
proofs and go through them and there was
no sense of
what are we actually doing here i needed
the why
in college i was fortunate enough to
take my geometry class with somebody who
was a theory guy
and really loved explaining and
unpacking these sorts of things
in a hegelian sense going and taking the
inner and making it outward
taking the outward and showing the
internality to it
if you can understand what we're talking
about there
and hegel says that what happens with
mathematical cognition
is people they do use the proof they do
derive the proof
but and the proof is connected with
its its result in the process
of proving it but then after that's done
you don't really need the proof anymore
it becomes purely ancillary
sort of like a beetle shedding it's it's
old skin you know once it's grown new
skin
and people are content with this and he
starts talking in terms of existence and
that might throw you a bit
you know he's talking in terms of
essence and existence
and mathematics is is primarily about
existence why the hell is he talking
about that
because mathematical knowledge is
existing
as something external for the knowing
subject
when we're talking about knowledge we
must never forget
that knowledge exists for a knowing
subject
knowledge exists in somebody's mind
in their understanding their intellect
and the knowing subject is sort of
extraneous it does you know think about
mathematics
uh a mathematical proof should be true
and should work
no matter who you're dealing with it
could be if you know some people are too
stubborn or too lazy
to actually comprehend it or they've got
some cognitive disabilities that keep
them from doing it or they're so
you know beset by anxiety that they
can't do it but in general if
there aren't any handicaps of that sort
somebody should be able to understand
mathematics to make sense of it and to
be able to get to
from here to here and then of course
they can leave that proof behind
hegel says um the result
it's as a result that the theorem is
something seemed to be true
but this added circumstance is no
bearing on its content only on its
relation to the knowing subject
so you know you could do mathematics
in a certain way just by going through
textbooks and
you know what textbooks in mathematics
really are they're put together
by people who are experts in mathematics
and they're designed to
get you through what it is
that they've learned
in the process and they do give you the
proofs but a lot of people just skip
over those and they go to the results
even very smart people hegel says the
way
this works for philosophical cognition
is different he says the way in which
the outer existence
qua existence of a thing comes about as
distinct from the way in which its
essence or inner nature comes to me
so we have this play between existence
the outer
and essence the the inner
what happens in philosophical cognition
is that these are not separated off from
each other
they actually undergo a kind of twisting
and
turning the essence that which is inner
has to be made external and thereby
become
existence he says
it this way um
the inner coming to being or genesis of
substance is
is an unbroken transition into outer
existence into being for another
being for the knowing subject
so as we think for example about the
nature of mathematics we're doing
philosophical cognition we ask ourselves
what is mathematics we try to grasp its
essence and then we
have to externalize it into determinate
existence
and then he says at the very same time
what's going on
in philosophical cognition the genesis
of existence is how existence
is by itself taken back into essence we
look at the
the individual the particular the
happens to be here at this point in time
and we try to find
what's really essential what it has in
common
with other things what it has to speak
to us about more than just itself
what is inward in it so the outer
becomes better the inner becomes outer
and this process is continually ongoing
so that we can't just say all right we
got the results
screw the the proofs screw the process
of
figuring this out now in philosophical
cognition
all of this still remains part of the
process again that's
why the phenomenology
has to lead us through all these
previous shapes of
consciousness